this there's an Indian word called
jugard right and jugar means are doing
whatever so make stuff happen so in
India you find channels of growth that
you might never find anywhere else for
example there's a large Ginger economy
in India right and so many of these
payment apps have used teamworkers to
actually physically visit the merchants
and get stuff done there welcome to 20
minute leaders just sit back relax and
learn from the leaders of today it's a
journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we are with shaival Desai the
chief growth officer of pet Puja shival
is the chief growth officer of pit Puja
and Next Generation restaurant
management platform offering
state-of-the-art point of sale software
to manage restaurant billing inventory
online orders menu and customers fondly
known as the Google of pet Puja by his
colleagues chival oversees the company's
marketing Advanced products in-house
sales and training along with his team
of professionals he also plays an
instrumental role in building pet puja's
Advanced products such as voice ordering
kiosk order serving robot waiter calling
devices Etc aside from these core
responsibilities Cheval drives SAS
implementation of the company to
streamline the processes for the other
teams
thank you for joining me today from
India correct that's right amazing
you're the chief growth officer of pet
Puja India's number one 1 restaurant
management software I'm excited to hear
all about that uh we you know it sounds
like I can mentioned right before we
started it sounds like you've had quite
an incredible incredible journey over
the last few months as the chief growth
officer previously uh several vice
president roles in agriculture before
that in different experiences tell me
just a little bit about pet Puja and
then I'd like to dive back into your own
journey and see how everything combines
together
okay perfect uh so paid Puja is India's
largest restaurant management platform
uh we provide a SAS platform to SNB
businesses uh with the primary focus on
small and medium businesses so while we
have Enterprise clients our Focus has
and will always be the small businesses
right and our software caters too so
today we have around 45 000 restaurants
that wow platform and uh so we handle
everything I mean our platform animals
everything from billing to inventory to
integration with the like suzumat or
swiggy and all of that so it's it's an
all-in-one uh software that you need at
your restaurant essentially incredible
so what what are what tell me a little
bit about sort of the world before pit
Puja and the world after in terms of the
Indian landscape these 45 000
restaurants what were they doing before
and what are they doing now
so uh India even today right even at 45
000 response is a blue ocean Market
um I mean no one really knows the real
number which is funny but India has uh
from our best customer uh estimate
anything between 20 to 40 lakh
Restaurants right and uh most of them
even before paid for then even today a
large majority are still using pen and
paper to jot out orders and some of them
are not even jotting them down right a
customer would just call and say Hey I
want one of this state and they would
base it out so uh yeah I mean I think we
have we've been successful in converting
a lot of those guys as well as yesterday
there exist a lot of software before bed
Puja also but what you gotta understand
is there has been a proliferation of b2c
apps in India right and these apps
interact with restaurants so for example
there is food delivery there's stable
reservation there's payments right and
uh restaurant uh cannot exist in silos
they have to yeah the software at
restaurants need to interact with these
apps which wasn't possible with the apps
of yesteryear and I think paid Pooja
really came in and changed that which is
why we saw massive adoption
so as Chief growth officer tell me a
little bit about growth in the Indian
landscape and specifically through the
lens of pet Puja what what is even grown
what what do you even Define growth as
at that point so uh so it's interesting
actually I need four different teams
here and I I see growth is very broadly
defined so I lead a lot of new
initiatives where we've launched a new
uh marketing product for restaurants I
need that completely I also handle
marketing and Deli sales so I took up
telesales because I had I was already
taking care of marketing and in
marketing unless you can close a loop
yeah you can you know you go from lead
to which ones uh take you know receive
but have actually paid for the product
and then funnel that data back into the
marketing channels you don't really know
what's happening so uh I I've been
leading multiple roles here
wow and so thinking about growth I mean
what what are what what are kind of sort
of I guess kpis or things that you
measure as you're growing is it is it is
it particularly number of restaurants
that are onboarding onto the platform
correct so uh basically a couple of
things first is uh obviously the
awareness the top of the funnel
awareness that restaurants should know
or a platform like this exists uh second
is uh having paid Puja into the
consideration funnel so uh they should
know that within the software that exist
Puja is providing the best services and
the best platform and uh third might
work also uh and so also involves having
them use more of the product right so uh
while this product is very deep in terms
of the features available what we have
seen that not more than 10 percent of
users uh so 90 of the users don't use
more than twenty percent of the product
right and uh my name is to get this
number up so we have gotten inventory
usage up from uh give or take ten
percent three years back to around 55
sent today and I want to make sure that
each module we provide is used because
the customer is already paid for it see
they pay for the platform support right
and I it's my job to ensure that they
can extract the maximum value out of it
right and so you're you're talking about
you know the the platform that they're
paying for it has you know invoices
different API considerations that you're
that you're providing different services
and what you're saying is a part of the
growth strategy he's not just external
growth to new customers but how do you
get internal customers to also really
make use of the entire platform
absolutely absolutely why is that so why
is that so critical because what you're
ever saying is you know they're already
paying for the product why is it not
enough that they have one or two
features that they're interested in why
is it important for you that the
leverage the remainder of the offering
that that Kuja has to offer so honestly
we feel that um see I started working in
this sector because I genuinely like
working with small businesses right and
we feel that the more modules they use
uh the more uh efficiency they can draw
out of their business right today most
of these small businesses are incredibly
inefficient right there are right a lot
of feel fridges there's a lot of food
wastage there's a there's actually
there's a lot of theft as well uh three
years back it was extremely high now I
think it come down but uh so we need to
make sure that these businesses can
extract maximum value out of it so that
they can you know actually increase
their margin especially with the
aggregators like zomato and swiggy
coming into play their margins have been
significantly hit right it's gone from
mid double digits to uh mid to high
single digits right and uh so it's it we
really want them they should make good
money and I think that's that's a large
part of the you know why we what we do
right why so why why do you do what you
do
I mean you yourself you you tell me a
little bit about your own Journey coming
into Puja okay sure so uh I'm actually a
mechanical engineer from the University
of Illinois at Romana Champaign uh I did
that I did completed my course came back
to India
um I took up agriculture right so I grew
roughly 400 tons of cucumbers and
roughly 100 tons of bell peppers uh very
interesting Journey there I think that
market also is completely uh inefficient
but I think I got so decent State uh I
realized that at 22 I think agriculture
was slightly snow right so uh in fact
you can put more effort into it and get
it done but the plant is going to take
the time it takes to grow you can't do
anything about it right so I realized
that it was a slightly slower business
that I want to be in and uh then in
parallel I completed two levels of the
financial analyst CFA right and uh I
actually went to intern for obesity fund
at the VC tiffan I realized that this is
so while I interacted with a ton of
startups I felt like I wanted to be
seated on the other side of the table
right I actually wanted to get my hand
dirty and build the business and which
is when I actually joined faithful and
uh the calling was essentially working
with these small businesses right so uh
their experiences in India I mean you
just when you work with an Enterprise
you're dealing with an organization it
is it's not a face right but with smbs
you are actually impacting real people
and some of them to a significant Excel
so for example right what what do you
think can be the impact of a software
now I was talking to a very interesting
right the owner of a pub who are in
Mobile and he gave a very interesting
example of how Peter had this town so uh
before Faith Puja hits this stuff the
pub would close around one his star
would take one to one and a half hours
to finish the reconciliation of the
invoices with each of the kitchen order
tokens if it went longer than that uh so
30 of the time they would miss their
trains they couldn't go back home to
sleep in the restaurant and start
working it with paid for that it gets
done in half an hour and they get to go
home every day right so you can actually
see the real impact you know on the
people on the blue collar workers that
it's creating and I think I genuinely
feel for them and uh that actually
motivates me to a large extent
and so tell me a little bit about the
you're mentioning a lot about the
discovery process of the impact you're
having your product is having on
customers what what what kind of
Discovery process do you go through as
you figure out the right products to
build the right products for different
organizations how you go to different
small businesses and you make sure that
they understand the way that you're
offering can can have such a significant
impact like the one that you just
mentioned
uh I mean most of it involves talking to
customers right and uh you talk to these
customers and a lot of times they will
narrate the problem in a certain way but
you've got to learn to read in between
the lines I think and then I think
that's true for most things in India
right you got and listen to their
problems and what they are not really
saying right and uh figure out that what
is going to have what feature or what
product is going to have the Maximum
Impact today so for example uh the new
product that we've launched is sort of a
canva for FNB but while I would call
canva a tool with uh creatives uh so
with the template study uh the product
that we have Twitter is more of a
template library with certain
customization tools right and it's
actually uh talking modern looks like
subtle difference but it's in fact large
because most of in most of the audience
doesn't know how how to use these stores
like canva right so we have ready-made
templates for them to just pick up edit
the text and publish right so be it
between thinking about how do we help
with marketing for quite a long time and
I think uh now is when we finally
discover that hey this is the way we we
wanted to help them uh you know achieve
the marketing goals as well
right and so tell me just a little bit
about your own day-to-day within pet
Puja you're with so many different
customers so many different use cases
how do you know how to spend your time
how do you differentiate between sort of
prioritization and what's important
what's less important
uh to be very honest in figuring it out
but uh I think uh 30 of my time is
putting out fires uh uh 20 is strategic
and fifty percent is operational right
so uh I think uh you know once I reach
office I figure out you know what's what
uh what's been burning where I need to
put out the fires and uh then I think
I'd go and think about whatever
strategic initiatives that I want to
take right and every day I mean I see
India is a kind of uh there's there's an
Indian word called right and jugar means
doing whatever so make stuff happen so
in India you find channels of growth
that you might never find anywhere else
so for example there's a large deal
economy in India right and so many of
these payment apps have used King
workers to actually physically visit the
merchants and get stuff done there right
and this kind of channel does it exist
so uh in most of I mean obviously we
have a traditional sales people also but
if you want to reach the smallest of
villages in town where it might not be
feasible to hire a full-time guy in
India you have an option of hiring gig
workers and pay them for app installed
or per Merchant onboarded right so uh
they're a very interesting channels that
keep coming up which are specific to
India so uh it's always you know
figuring out which one works so for
example Facebook or Google ads are
obviously it works in India but the
thing is uh we have so many users who
click on an ad fill out the form and
don't really want the product or haven't
you don't even know what the product is
right and this doesn't happen in most of
the world so uh there and it might so
happen that the thing workers might be a
better Channel than visit direct digital
marketing so it's always figuring out
that balance right and I think that's
where a lot for the day also goes
interesting interesting take me back a
little bit to your own upbringing kind
of you know the type of impact that you
want to have you know as a tech
executive as a tech leader because
obviously in your role you're you're
impacting a lot of people where does
this originate from
um so
I mean both my bad my uh grandfather was
a politician here she has worked at the
Grassroots level uh he was a farmer
before he became a politician and he has
had tremendous impact on the state where
I live in it's the western state of
Gujarat which is where uh Prime Minister
Modi is from uh both my parents and
doctors
um so I think through both of their
Journeys I think I've always wanted to
have a positive impact on our society be
it through Tech and be it otherwise
right and I think that actually taught
me that hey this is a while I want to
you know uh while all I mean I want to
succeed in the business that I'm doing I
also want the business to have a real
impact on uh businesses on other
businesses that use the platform I think
uh that's that's where where it is come
from
interesting interesting and so going
back to sort of India today the vision
of pet Puja if we're going down the line
what what is sort of the vision of the
company and where where do you see it
heading
uh so we see India as being the de facto
platform for smbs globally so
um I mean we have a very clearly charted
out journey in terms of how we want to
expand from Indian fnbs to Global fnbs
and we're releasing a couple of products
that will actually take us horizontal so
I don't mean all smbs but uh rather I
would say a global product for retail
SMB retails modern medium businesses it
could be food retail it could be
clothing
retail right but we have a clear road
map to be the default SMB retail
platform for the world
and Global SMB retail for the world and
so what what does it take to then expand
outside of India in that case
uh I think uh I mean we already have
expanded outside of India we are already
present in the UAE and South African
Market uh I mean we're not uh we just
started there I think it's been uh five
or six odd months right uh but I think
there even over there there is I mean we
are we're seeing the market is humongous
and there is very good exceptions of
Indian tech products so uh and obviously
you know you always have to consider
Uprising see we are extremely
competitive in our price especially when
it when you compare it to our products
from Western countries and providing
similar functionality so we are going to
be able to win out there and that's what
we are seeing in the market
interesting is there any resistance from
the market man it just sounds okay is it
a fairy tale right is there any
resistance from Smalls from small
businesses any of them saying no we want
to stay the way we are we're not
interested in these processes
so there are two challenges in this
industry as of all right of course the
first one you mentioned is yes there are
a lot of people who say we are okay with
pen and paper right and that's fine I
mean we have seen the wave of
digitization post covet wherein you know
literally uh business I the inquiries
that we're generating went up to us
right but another problem with SMB is
this churn right uh smbs uh actually
businesses die and in smbs in in the
food and business uh food beverage small
business segment that we're in uh we see
up to 30 percent of customers die every
year so the businesses die right and so
we uh or have to one get more business
from the businesses Merchants that are
on our platform and second keep on
acquiring new Merchants right uh I think
over time it's getting slightly easier
because uh you know we are already there
covering a large portion or I mean
covering a decent side of the market it
so there's already a good restaurant
market so there's a lot of inbound leads
but yes the churn is always going to be
a challenge
right and that that's interesting and so
is do you see the consumer Behavior
shifting at all over these last several
years as this is as you've been entering
the market and you've been seeing I mean
you're not alone there's no there's a
whole digitization happening right now
do you see the conversation shifting and
anything happening around
um anything interesting happening that
you've observed the shift over the last
few years
so very interestingly I was just talking
to someone about this right and uh we
used to we've been going to uh FNB
conferences for I mean Central mean of
the company I've been attending them
right and up to two years back they were
about you know they would call in uh
Resto doors from large chains and
discuss operations and supply chain and
whatnot right and since the past two
years thirty percent of the conversation
has been dedicated to technology and
that's a huge shift that just shows how
interested flbs are in adopting
technology and how large of a
conversation is becoming for that right
and just to give put numbers in context
right uh the talk in in a fortune
thousand uh they spend roughly five
percent of their revenue on technology
uh for developed Market smbs that number
is close to two percent so they spent
wow percent of their revenue and
technology in India that number is below
0.1 percent wow yeah so there's a huge
Headroom even all technology spend if
you look at holistic number and uh bear
in mind that you're talking uh even the
revenues are a 10 and out of that
they're spending 0.1.2 percent right so
it's it's a very small number today and
there's a tremendous Headroom to grow
they're just waking up today to the
advantages of digitization and how much
efficiency it can bring in right say uh
you know if you reduce inventory cost by
15 to 20 which is not difficult to
digital digitalization directly you're
impacting your net margins by three or
four percent right and which is a huge
which is a huge youth number right when
you look at the when you'll say that
okay uh today my margin is say net
margin is nine to ten percent and I'm
taking it to 13 or 14 and you're seeing
like a 30 to 40 increase in the net
margin in the network person is taking
hold
incredible well I have a 10 more
questions that I off the top mid right
now that I had that I would want to ask
here but I have to stay true to the
format of the show and Chevelle I really
want to thank you for coming here and
sharing with me a little bit about your
own your own personal passion for what
you're doing the impact that you're
having with pet Puja the some of the the
different challenges or the different
opportunities that you're presenting
here and a little bit about what's
happening in the Indian landscape so I
really appreciate you coming here and
best of luck continue growing pet Puja
to be the market leader and then I look
forward to cheering from the side
thank you so much foreign
thank you thank you very very much thank
you
[Music]